what if we ask ourselves this question
all the time at Carnegie Mellon
University
what if students were immersed in a
collaborative learning environment where
open spaces translate into open ideas
what if the world's most forward-looking
business school created the education of
the future to prepare the next
generation of leaders to be pioneers of
change in a dynamic global world what if
we unleashed innovation by giving
promising entrepreneurs from every
corner of CMU access to a center that
merges business technology and design
what if every prospective student parent
alum supporter partner and visitor could
feel welcomed and wowed as they
experience the richness of CMU first
hand what if emerging business
executives harness the latest practices
expertise and coaching to accelerate
their growth and transform industries
what if students can become global
citizens by connecting with cultures
through a multimedia rich interactive
learning space
what if educators revolutionized
learning by developing new technologies
and techniques with state of the art
classrooms and teaching innovation
studios
[Music]
what if every student every faculty
member every target had access had the
inspiration had the place to create to
build to innovate to accelerate the
convergence of ideas to solve the
world's greatest challenges what if two
words that represent the future of ha
Carnegie Mellon is empowering tomorrow's
thinkers innovators and discoverers
giving them the tools to stretch the
limits of our imagination now as we
celebrate the opening of the Tempur quad
we are prepared to go beyond what if
today we ask what next please welcome
the Dean of The Temper School of
Business
Robert Daymond WoW is all I have to say
what do you think
I think that video really captures the
essence of what this building is meant
to be and really captures the essence of
what the future for Carnegie Mellon in
the temporary School of Business have
has to hold I'm very excited about today
I want to thank all of you for being
here I almost feel like I'm in the
Coliseum to be quite honest with you I
you know a funds up thumbs down anyway
thank you for being here and it's my
pleasure to welcome all of you here to
the grand opening of this amazing
building on the David Keppler quadrangle
this is really a very special day for us
it's one that we've been anticipating
for a very very long time and I want to
thank you and welcome you to this
amazing celebration that we're having
here today and tomorrow I want to extend
some special welcomes to the members of
our Carnegie Board Carnegie Mellon Board
of Trustees The Temper School of
Business Board of Advisors that CMU
Alumni Association Board and The Temper
School Alumni Board who have joined us
here today I also want to thank and
welcome members of the university
leadership who are in attendance
including my fellow Dean's I've seen
many of them in the audience thank you
for being here as well as the University
of vice-presidents thank you all for
being here today there are also several
government officials who have joined us
today
Allegheny County Executive rich
Fitzgerald I saw rich a little bit
earlier rich there you are thank you
rich for being here Mayor Bill Peduto
could not be here today but representing
Mayor Peduto is his chief of staff and
CMU alumnus dan Gilman dan thank you
both thank you both for being here this
building is really a manifestation of
years of planning and hard work on the
part of many individuals it's hard to
believe quite honestly but the
discussions about a new building for the
Tempur school really started more than a
decade ago
even before I became the Dean but it was
only three years ago if you'll remember
that we broke ground on this very
location for this building and in those
short three years this magnificent
building has risen from the ground it's
really quite an awe-inspiring to see
what has been accomplished in those
three years on behalf of the entire
Carnegie Mellon and tempura school
community I want to thank all of those
who helped to bring this beautiful and
amazing business building to life I'd
like to take the opportunity to
recognize a few individuals and thank
them for the key roles that they played
in our efforts first our architect buz
Udell and his amazing team from more
rouble in you Dell buzzes in the front
here buz you're not an architect buz
you're not an architect you're an artist
actually this is a beautiful beautiful
building and I knew from the very first
day that I met was and his team that
they were in fact the right partners for
this for this project and I'm so pleased
with how everything turned out buzz
thank you for everything that you've
done for us amazing simply amazing
you've created a design obviously that
is not only visually beautiful but it's
also one that energizes people to
explore to connect and to collaborate
cliff ro and Jeff Turco nee from the PJ
dick our construction manager who did a
fantastic job of managing the
complexities of this huge building and
the in managing a tight time schedule as
well for the project our Carnegie Mellon
project leads a Ralph Oregon and Bob
revi from campus design and facility
development they're here
and from the temper school Brian
Rutledge I don't know his Brian here
today god bless
Brian Rutledge I have to say he spent so
much time on this project over the last
five years representing the temperate
school representing Carnegie Mellon he's
just done just a fantastic job he's not
here today because he broke his ankle
but I think he will be here this
afternoon he's gonna wheel in on in a
wheelchair and he'll be here later this
afternoon he learned more about bubble
decking cement and in raised floors than
anybody that would want to know those
things that you know you worked
extremely hard together and you're still
talking to one another which is a good
thing and I think it's it's really been
a team effort and I want to thank you
for all that you've done on this project
thank you
on-time on-budget remember I'd also like
to thank all the individuals who served
on the Tempur quad steering committee
from all across campus including Mike
Trick a longtime faculty member and
former senior associate dean at the
Tepper School and the current Dean of
the CMU campus in Qatar I think Mike is
here he's traveled all the way to Doha
there he is Mike thank you for being
here
if they thank you also for all the work
that you put into this project
and of course the hundreds of faculty
staff students artisans trades people
who contributed their ideas their skills
energy and their labor to bring this
magnificent project to life our lead
benefactor on this project David Tepper
has said from the outset that this
should be more than a great building it
should also be a great idea and that
simple but very powerful statement has
influenced our thinking on this project
from the very beginning our common
vision was to create a space that would
not only serve as the new home for the
Tepper School of Business but would also
be a space that would serve as a vibrant
hub of intellectual and social activity
for all of Carnegie Mellon a place that
would showcase and elevate CMU's culture
of cross campus collaboration and
interdisciplinary problem-solving I
believe that this building achieves that
and much much more
for the Tempur school this building and
this collaborative environment that it
creates provides us the opportunity to
reimagine business education and
research for the 21st century we intend
to deepen the already strong
intellectual connections that between
the Tempur school and CMU's other
world-class schools and colleges to
create a research and a learning
environment that is unmatched among
business schools with the needs of
business and the needs of the world
really now converging on the strengths
of Carnegie Mellon and The Temper School
I think we are uniquely positioned to
provide the intellectual leadership and
to educate the next generation of
business leaders and entrepreneurs to be
the agents of change in this new world
that's being driven by technology and
information in addition to providing the
physical infrastructure and support
of this transformative agenda for the
temper school and for CMU this new
building also provides other amenities
that will benefit the entire CMU campus
we are very thrilled to embark on this
exciting new chapter of The Temper
School and Carnegie Mellon University
and really discover the true potential
of this building thank you all very much
for being here now I would like to
welcome interim provost Laurie Winegard
to the stage from 2014 to 2017 Laurie
was senior associate dean at The Temper
school and also played a critical role
key role in this project she was
involved in the planning of the Tempur
quad from its early stages and helped
steer the project to what it has become
today so please join me in welcoming
interim provost Laurie wine guy
[Applause]
well thanks Dean Damon and good
afternoon to everyone it's wonderful to
see you up there
Cheryl good to see ya okay um as I've
spent time here today walking around the
building looking into all the rooms I'm
so thrilled and I am so proud to see all
the members of the Carnegie Mellon
family here today sharing this
experience with us I want to welcome our
colleagues from across campus all of our
returning tartan alumni and most
importantly all of our students you get
to study and interact in this amazing
new space in the Tempur building through
its architecture and through its design
you can just feel the interdisciplinary
boundaries there is permeable as the
moveable walls in the new space we need
to open them up bring everybody in with
countless meeting space social areas
classrooms and offices will strengthen
our culture of collaboration in our
academic and professional pursuits
across all disciplines and across new
intellectual Plains because that's what
we do at Carnegie Mellon and The Temper
quad is the new hub where we can make it
all happen this building is now home to
many of our newest spaces in which we
will innovate and Excel and the
education that we provide so while
you're here visit the new technology
enhanced learning center it's on the
first floor where state-of-the-art
experimental classrooms will catalyze
educational innovation for CMU students
today and for generations to come and
while you're there drop in on the
Asquith kenner classroom that provides a
technology rich interactive learning
experience devoted to the study of
global languages and cultures these
spaces alongside Tepper building
classrooms and innovation hubs create a
campus environment like no other as we
set forth on the next phase of the quad
we'll stay true to
our mission of providing what our
students need to excel in their studies
research and all the countless
opportunities that lie ahead
so please join me in congratulating
everybody and let's first just say thank
you to the architects and now it's my
pleasure to introduce the tenth
president of Carnegie Mellon University
dr. Furnham Jehan Ian good afternoon
what an exciting day to be here at
Carnegie Mellon University first of all
how's the weather up there on the fifth
floor fourth floor the future is so
bright
we gotta wear shades
[Applause]
those who applauded showed their age by
the way you know I gotta get something
off my chest this building says a lot
about who we are as an institution and
where we're going on behalf of the
entire CMU community let me extend a
warm welcome as we celebrate this grand
opening first I would like to
acknowledge our Business School Dean Bob
Damon
leadership of the tempers school and of
course our Provost Lori weingartz thank
you again for your leadership
we shared this special occasion with our
trustees and our partners members of the
university leadership alumni and
supporters honored guests from the
community as well as faculty students
and staff from across campus of course
this incredible facility would not be
possible without the leadership and
generosity of David Tepper CMU alumnus
trustee and legendary benefactor
David's passion for this project is
driven by the belief that
carnegie-mellon draws its greatest
strength from our willingness to cross
boundaries so he challenged and
empowered us to create a building that
would enhance this innate ability we're
so grateful for his foundational
generosity which was supported along the
way by friends and donors who believed
in this vision and what it could do for
Carnegie Mellon you know this is quite a
month for David newly engaged
he had his birthday this week and now
we're about to celebrate another
tremendous milestone we built you a
building for your birthday David David
I'm so thrilled to welcome you and your
family back to campus for this
celebration including your fiance Nicole
I'm also grateful for the generosity and
leadership of our Tepper quad
fundraising campaign chairs Jack McGrath
and David Coulter Jack and David thank
you for bringing your passion and
dedication as tougher alumni for this
project and also for your commitment and
service as our university trustees thank
you again I would also like to welcome
and acknowledge Jim and Susan Schwarz in
Jim and Susan provided a landmark 31
million dollar gift to establish the
Swartz Center for Entrepreneurship at
CMU a hub for entrepreneurial activities
that has its home here on the Tempur
quad Jim and Susan thank you for all
that you have done to support this
university's entrepreneurial culture
[Applause]
in total 1249 donors made philanthropic
contributions to support this historic
project I am so pleased to acknowledge
and congratulate these generous alumni
and friends many of whom have joined us
today at this time please join me in
showing our profound appreciation to
these supporters
I'm sure all of you recognize our
society is going undergoing massive
disruption due to breathtaking pace a
fourth of the fourth Industrial
Revolution advanced technologies are
impacting every sector of our economy
education is key to staying ahead of
this fast-moving current to make the
most of these opportunities that lie
ahead we must be willing to disrupt the
system of higher education itself the
future of Education in the 21st century
will depend on breaking down
disciplinary silos it will be forged by
diverse minds coming together for
learning and research as an institution
grounded in relentless creativity and
driven by fearless entrepreneurial
spirit Carnegie Mellon knows how to do
this better than anyone else we're
leading this transformation in higher
education
armed with bold optimism and big ideas
know where is the potential for what's
next are more palpable than right here
in the Tapper quad certainly as the new
home of our business school this
building will enhance CMU's diverse
strengths at the intersection of
business technology and society here we
will nurture the next generation of
leaders here we will catalyze deeper
connections between tappers school and
the other core areas of excellence
across our campus including computer
science engineering social sciences and
the arts more than 300,000 square feet
the Tepper quad will also serve as a
campus hub to place where all members of
our community can
create innovate and explore a culture of
connection everything about this
building is designed to support our
research and education mission 24 state
of the art classrooms a new center for
technology enhanced learning and
interactive global languages and
cultures room a gorgeous new auditorium
for convening our community and of
course the Tempur quad also recognizes
and celebrates the central role of
universities at engines of new discovery
innovation and economic development with
the built-in resources of the Swartz
Center we will help entrepreneurs from
across campus conceive launch and lead
new endeavors as the new front door of
Carnegie Mellon University this building
says a lot about who we are as an
institution and where we're going when
visitors walk into this building through
the David and Susan Coulter Welcome
Center right off of Forbes Avenue they
will understand right away this is a
university while all perspectives are
welcome here's where great ideas are
born and nurtured today The Temper quad
opens its doors to new possibilities
making the beginning of one of the most
important and inspiring chapters in
CMU's history I am truly honored to
celebrate this historic occasion
surrounded by our supporters and so many
members of our community I can't wait to
see what comes next at this time it's my
pleasure to introduce someone who is not
only a generous donor to the Tempur quad
but also a leader who has championed
this effort for its long-term impact on
Carnegie Mellon ladies and gentlemen
please join me in welcoming the chair of
the Carnegie
Board of Trustees mr. Jim roar Jim thank
you very much Farnum for the wonderful
introduction wow this is really
intimidating this is quite amazing if
you just when I look you just have to
stop and imagine just stop and imagine
what's going to take place in this
building over the next 20 30 40 years
the innovation that will take place and
as you as you go through the building
and you think about and Farnam said how
it's the center of campus imagine what's
going to take place for the CMU
community in the Simmons auditorium and
the strong auditorium and some of the
other some of the other large rooms the
entrepreneurial space for the Schwartz
Center think what's going to take place
in there with the young people it's also
good for Pittsburgh because I'm pretty
sure that there's going to be a lot of
regional meetings that take place right
here in this building Farnum talked
about the education for the students and
the collaborative nature of the students
but also the faculty I think there's
going to be an argument about who gets
to use all of these buildings it's a
prediction but all these rooms but
collaboration is key the prospects we've
never really been too inviting I know
that we've asked asked the families of
applicants to come on in to warner Hall
that's not the most welcoming
arrangement they ever seen the new Susan
and David Coulter thing will be a
senator will be much greater and for the
alums to come back and just hang here
this is the center of campus imagine
imagine what might take place here now
before I get started let me first just
thank Farnum Farnum as the Provost as
the interim president and as the
president your leadership has been
tireless in terms of making sure that
the idea
of the temper building and the temper
quad came to fruition actually even
better than we thought so
Farnum thank you very much for your
leadership by the way just to remind you
on October the 26th the inauguration
will take place we hope that most if not
all of you are back for that that should
be a very exciting place so thank you
again congratulations on your
inauguration - let me also just take a
second and behalf of the trustees to
thank that large group of staff whether
it meant the university staff Ralph and
his team PJ dick cliff and all the boys
the architects and all the people
including the The Temper Committee there
was a trustee committee put together
chaired by David that met regularly to
make sure this building ended up being
exactly what the image was so I want to
thank all of those people all the ones
that we could give them a round of
applause so we have a great day we have
a remarkable group here this crowd
really is reflective of the breadth of
the Carnegie Mellon community and we've
heard about many people talk about the
temperate quad success of the
opportunities here but I'm really here
to just talk about one individual really
and the story about David Tepper is well
known that of a hometown boy went out of
the world the fellow that grew up only a
few blocks for a few miles from here
where we stand today attended school
high school in East Liberty went to Pitt
and got an economics degree and went off
into the business world it was a short
time later that CMU came into the
picture has been a common refrain
refrain in David's life when something
wasn't going as well as he wanted he
took charge and he changed his own
course which is really good for us
because that's how at the age of 23
David came to see him you and proneural
that Carnegie Mellon to pursue his
Master of Science in industrial
administration which
today would be an MBA ten years after
graduation a similar situation took
place where David wasn't as pleased with
how things were going so he took
ownership of his future density destiny
again Restless in a cultured structured
environment he started his own firm
Appaloosa management and boy what a firm
it is the company's risen to the top of
its industry that's a more successful
than any other fund family and much of
David's success can be attributed to his
willingness to put his money behind his
convictions which were based upon his
vision of the future and then managed
the risk as that investment came to
fruition and he also employed the
critical analytical thinking that CMU
helped him Davout develop during his
time here it was really taking advantage
of the vision he had at the future today
a friend of his Stanley Druckenmiller
said that without a doubt over the last
20 years David Tepper is the greatest
investor in the world I think that's
pretty nice
I don't to talk about it in terms of CMU
terms
I remember when Fred Astaire once said
that he thought that Michael Jackson was
the greatest dancer he'd ever seen I
would compare that to Druckenmiller is
Kevin about you for those up there that
would be Bruno Mars but anyway where
would David and I've been colleagues on
the CMU Board of Trustees since 2004
he's also on the Tempur school board
business Board of Advisors and he's not
a shy man for those of you who know it
he's he's kind of convicted he's
convinced of his his opinions and he's
been very forthright in driving the
board to a more aspirational point of
view and I think this building in his
example is exactly that he wants to see
his alma mater ascend to the greatest
heights in which it could possibly
achieve and I think he's done an
enormous amount to to get us there
the other thing that happens is he's
remarkably philanthropic I remember when
I the second time that I had seen him on
squawk box he talked about his
philanthropy in New Jersey at the time
and that obviously has come to us here
at Carnegie Mellon he's one of our most
generous benefactors ever his gifts have
transformed the business school as
you've seen in 2004 he gave what was at
that time the largest single gift effort
in the university's history 55 million
dollars to change the name of the
business school to The Temper School of
Business providing not only resources
but also a review renewed energy in
order to energize the business school to
change their identity for the future
when he made this gift David called it
an investment in the school's legacy
they more important than investment and
confidence for its future less than a
decade later David made another
extraordinary gift to empower CMU to
achieve its long-held dream of a major
expansion across Forbes Avenue his 67
million dollar gift was the lead gift
and for the temper quad and stands as
one of the most generous single gifts
ever received and the largest ever to
support the capital project in
university history he also challenged us
at that time he said I'm willing to give
you this gift only if the rest of you
support this project and as foreign him
said that encouraged 1200 plus other
people to make their own statements of
support for this facility again it was
David's vision as to how this should
come together from the beginning he said
this was not to be just the business
building here in addition to the
business school he wanted to have large
spaces devoted to collaboration he
wanted to have faculty and staff from
all over CMU teach here he wanted a
Welcome Center he wanted dining
facilities he wanted spaces for their
families and visitors for C of U but
really it's a Center for teaching and
innovation and the hub of
entrepreneurship for the entire campus
and I think as you take a look at it and
you watch the foot traffic this is the
center of campus
this division aligns perfectly with
where the trustees the staff and the
faculty Steve the strategic plan of
Carnegie Mellon going forward and I
think it aligns directly with what's
going on here
the edge of per diem entrepreneurial
mindset at CMU is everywhere and our
researchers constantly consider how they
take their discoveries and transform
them into real-world impact the term
imagine what you can do here really
comes to life here in the Tempur quad so
frankly we are very very fortunate to be
where we are the university has been
built based upon a tremendous amount of
work of thousands of people over a long
period of time and yet this building and
David's vision gives us the opportunity
to take the building to take the
university to yet another level let me
take this opportunity before I ask
Farnum to come back David
on behalf of the trustees and all of the
Carnegie Mellon family thank you so much
for what you've done for us thank you
Jim for your continued leadership and
for your commitment to Carnegie Mellon
once again let's thank Jim we were
honored to have David Tepper as our
keynote speaker at cm used most recent
commencement ceremony in his closing
remarks he issued a challenge to our
remarkable graduating students
he said when all of you become
successful remember give back give back
no one has lived up to that guiding
principle more than David Tepper himself
I am thrilled to welcome to the stage
demand behind the Tepper Business School
and a temper quad business leader
investment icon philanthropist Business
School alumnus University trustee and
Carnegie Mellon champion David Allen
tapper David
thank you thank you I can't see you guys
over in the corner there how you guys
doing today up there you can see okay
well you know they talked about vision a
few times they gave me this I don't know
if I'm supposed to see better thank you
you're gonna let me have the microphone
to say that to me today he said I look
better so anyways I just want to thank
everybody today foreign him Jim Bob
countless other people Ralph
even Jeff from my office but Brian
Rutledge who has a I'm really upset that
he's not here today because he really
did so much and really put it in his
heart Jim Schwartz I'm not gonna thank
you
you just made Craig no no any place and
just countless others I mean it really
was a fantastic effort to put this thing
together and I don't know hopefully
everybody I don't know if everybody's
downstairs walked around here and I'm
hopefully you guys up up there I've
walked around this building it really
the open space is the idea that this
building can change with the times I
think just walking through the building
you can fill that in the building I
guess it was five or six years ago or
maybe was seven years ago before
previous presidents that we first
started talking about this or thinking
about this and through a couple
presidents we kept doing this and five
years ago we really came together with
this vision of doing a a business goal
with was just not a business goal a
business goal that was just more than a
silo where you would be in a corner of
campus and just do business education
but a
but a place where you really would have
people come it was it was sort of like a
field of dreams anybody ever see that
movie filled with dreams and in the
movie in that movie they said if you
build it they will come so we build it
you know and you know the idea is that
we'll have people commingle from all
around campus to you know to spread it
to share ideas and in just a different
way of doing business and this this
building I mean just walk around this
building whether you're up at the Swart
Center upstairs or anyplace in this
building you can just feel it this is a
different place than any other place on
campus and pretty much any a different
place than any other building or
university particularly a business in
this country
so this university has been one that's
led the way in innovation and hopefully
this building is something that leads a
way to I have to tell you this is
actually the first I've been to the
building at different times but this the
first time I've seen this building
absolutely done and it's it's pretty
fantastic I hate to bring another movie
anybody ever see Independence Day
anybody seen that movie Independence Day
you know when they when they when I
guess it's Jeff Goldblum and who's the
other actor that were up there huh Will
Smith they came back they got shot down
right and they you know they could walk
him back with a cigar in his mouth after
they just shut down the alien vessel and
the President of the United States at a
time he goes after they just basically
saved the world he goes not too bad not
too bad at all well this place is
fantastic so I'll tell you not too bad
not too bad at all
again I just want to thank everybody
involved and just that helped build this
place put this place together so with
that I'm kind of hungry I'm gonna let
everybody eat lunch so thank you very
much
thank you thank you thank you thank you
David as always we're inspired by your
words and of course your generosity and
now we're gonna have a lot of fun the
moment you've been waiting for
yo he's not gonna cut their friend just
by himself
I would like to invite a few people to
join David Nicole and me as we
officially opened David a tephra David a
temper quadrangle gym roar David culture
Jack McGrath Jim and Susan Schwarz
Laurie Weingard Bob Damon and
representing our Carnegie Mellon student
body
Ross Metta student body president let's
hear it for Raj
[Applause]
Victoria Lopez peppers school MBA
candidate there you go
and Elizabeth Campbell pepper school PhD
candidate
[Applause]
[Music]